- I just don't take
movies that seriously.
I mean, if I did, I'd believe
that every time I got on
a mother (bleeps) plane
there'd be some mother
(bleeps) snakes!
(laughter erupts)
Which I do, but that serves
me right for flying Spirit.
- I thought it was
cool that it did show
what it's like to
come home from war
but the love story was meh.
The female lead in it
was one dimensional.
It was the same scene
over and over again
with her being like,
don't go to war,
don't go to war, don't
go to war and it's like,
bitch, this is the best
shooter in the worlds.
He's gotta go to war.
She was like a broken Roomba
just banging against
the same wall.
- As a sniper, do you think
Lee Harvey Oswald did it?
- I don't think
he was by himself.
(audience oohs and applauds)
- There's no way I'm
giving a sniper weak tea.
(laughter erupts)
Easiest question ever.
Hey America, Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook, too.
Just don't poke me.
I do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.